es martes de debate presidencial en eeuu
bienvenidos a economía quién france24 y
para hablar de este y otros temas
económicos tenemos a la especialista
daniel hablando ramírez bienvenida a
propósito de este cara a cara que se
juega en elecciones en términos
económicos aquí en eeuu alan muy buenas
noches pues esta elección podría tener
efectos dramáticos en los mercados y los
analistas ya están tratando de
identificar los ganadores y los
perdedores sobre todo entre quienes
invierten en bolsa estas son las
diferencias entre ambos candidatos un
análisis de la agencia reuters dice que
un segundo mandato de donald trump
podría traer consigo más recortes de
impuestos el presidente también ha sido
partidario de la desregularización
bancaria y no es muy amigo de las
exenciones arancelarias ya que la guerra
comercial con china de la que todos
sabemos por el lado de joe biden su plan
consiste en aumentar impuestos lo que
muchos creen que añadiría más presión a
las empresas en esta época de crisis el
candidato demócrata ha mostrado afinidad
con proyectos
energía renovable y de infraestructura
como dato adicional alan en medio de la
polémica por la declaración de impuestos
de donald trump el candidato yo va a
tener monstruos en la suya y dijo que él
y su esposa pagaron 346 mil dólares en
2019 seguro abordará el tema yo bailé en
el día de hoy en la serie en el debate
vamos ahora a europa y es que avanza la
nueva ronda de negociaciones entre el
reino unido y la unión europea esto en
términos del bridge sí señor y en lugar
de lograr un acuerdo
londres y bruselas podrían distanciarse
todavía más y le voy a decir porque
justo hoy la cámara de los comunes en
londres dio luz verde a la polémica
legislación que les permite modificar
unilateralmente el acuerdo de retirada
reino unido busca mantener abierta la
frontera entre las dos irlandas aún si
tiene que sacrificar parte de sus
compromisos ya adquiridos pero en
bruselas ha exigido que retiren este
proyecto que todavía necesita aprobación
de la cámara de los lores y dice que si
no lo hacen acudirá a instancias
internacionales en todo caso sí no
hay un acuerdo ahora a partir del
primero de enero no se sabrá qué reglas
van a regir el comercio entre estas dos
recién divorciadas seguimos en este
continente daniela y es que las
autoridades europeas tienen en la mira a
las cripto monedas porque mire los
cripto activos son un esquema de
inversión y de pagos virtual que han
venido tomando fuerza en los últimos
años inclusive facebook tiene su propia
cripto moneda pero no se pueden
considerar dinero y están poco regulados
la policía francesa capturó hoy a 29
personas que hacían parte de un esquema
de financiación de al qaeda y del grupo
estado islámico esto mediante el uso de
bitcoins en síria lo que hacían era que
ya no enviaban dinero en efectivo a
estos países en guerra sino que
compraban cupones de cripto monedas y
los destinatarios podían retirar estos
cupones después pueden cambiarse por
dinero en efectivo en línea sin dejar
casi que ningún rastro de la operación
mientras tanto la policía española por
otro lado investiga el caso de a
revistar 2.0
esta es una firma que reconoce
tener 32 mil afectados con inversiones
por unos 90 y 34 millones de euros ellos
no han podido acceder a su dinero a alan
por un supuesto error informático y
entablaron una demanda este es
justamente uno de los riesgos con estas
inversiones que en estos casos es
difícil encontrar a quién acudir vamos a
brasil daniela y es que hay discute en
la extensión de ayudas por la pandemia
de coronavirus si en el seno del
gobierno están buscando fórmulas que
permitan extender el gasto en subsidios
a partir de enero próximo antes de la
pandemia alrededor de 40 millones de
brasileños recibían mensualmente lo
equivalente a 36 dólares mensuales en
esto en el marco del programa bolsa
familia con la pandemia ese valor subió
a unos 110 dólares y ahora cubre a 65
millones de personas entre ellos miles
de trabajadores informales y quienes
perdieron sus empleos pues el presidente
yair bolsonaro advirtió en sus redes que
la ayuda de emergencia no puede ser
eterna como lo quieren los que llamo
demagogos y comunistas y que vigilará el
gasto público
indicadores económicos de la las bolsas
estuvieron hoy en modo elecciones
pendientes del debate presidencial por
eso hubo pocos cambios en wall street en
europa las bolsas también bajarán en
parís es una noticia importante fue el
inicio de las subastas para las primeras
frecuencias de 5g y en américa latina'
el golpe fue para brasil en donde
todavía hay mucha incertidumbre
económica es 29 de septiembre de daniela
con esta cifra el día los 28.000
trabajadores de los parques temáticos de
disney que serán despedidos por la
pandemia muy bien daniela pues muchas
gracias por el recorrido económico y a
ustedes muchas gracias por la compañía
siguen france24
[Música]